diese Erdbeer Raffaello Torte schmeckt
unheimlich erfrischend und ist super
schnell zubereitet für den blitzboden
werden Eier ein bisschen Wasser und
Zucker miteinander verrührt sobald die
Vanille Extrakt mehl und Backpulver dazu
gegeben habt wird das Ganze eingefüllt
und gebackt wird die blitzschnelle
Raffaello Creme werden ganz einfach alle
Zutaten erst langsam miteinander
verrührt und dann war immer schneller
werdender Geschwindigkeit komplett steif
geschlagen dabei gebt ihr noch die kalte
Schlagsahne mit dazu Sahnefest darf
nicht fehlen und fertig ist die
leckerste Raffaello Creme komplett ohne
Gelatine ich bereite diese Torte
übrigens mit einem Durchmesser von 26 cm
zu wer eine kleinere Form möchte zum
Beispiel 20 cm kann einfach die Hälfte
der Zutaten verwenden schichtet die
Creme jetzt abwechselnd mit frischen
Erdbeeren und garniert das ganze mit
Raffaello Erdbeeren und Kokos Chips ich
schreibe euch natürlich alles ganz genau
noch mal auf also müsst euch das nicht
merken und könnte das ganz einfach
nachmachen